more than a million lined the streets to
celebrate the end of the war with
Germany but this year the 75th
anniversary those streets are set to be
empty events up and down the country
planned for months and years canceled
the ones who fought bravely on the
battlefields now trapped inside we've
locked down unlikely to end by Friday
there's little chance of parties like
these at the 70th anniversary in 2015
for the former head of the British Army
insists the country has a duty to
commemorate any way it can v-day is a
very special day and the 75th
anniversary of d-day is particularly
special when we cast our minds back to
the previous generation who fought so
valiantly for the peace and freedom of
Liberty that we take for granted today
it's really important that we
commemorate those who fell and celebrate
the service of those who saw us through
those difficult days of the Second World
War I hope you'll really celebrate the
e75 in the best way we can even though
we're still in this terrible lockdown
it means coming up with creative ways to
mark the anniversary at home for this
charity workshop in Kent veterans are
manning the machines creating special
perspex figurines of tommy soldiers the
aim for households up and down the
country to put them on window sills a
visual show of support for servicemen
and women past and present this is a
very emotional time for me
packing at tommy it it's not only
celebrating or should I say celebrating
the lives that gave us a freedom but
it's also a poignant moment because I
lost 56 comrades on the Sir Galahad when
I was in the Falklands so this is very
emotional
like many charities Royal British Legion
Industries is struggling during
coronavirus income has dropped by 70%
three-quarters of staff have been
furloughed the money from the figurines
will go to supporting veteran care homes
and those living alone during lockdown
people in the wider public are
understanding the sacrifices that the
services have given not only during the
footman first in the second world war
but also nowadays you see servicemen and
women on the front line doing testing
you see people here working and that
recognition and that unbroken line of
service to their country has actually
been a tremendous amount never more
evident than the now Colonel Tom Moore's
sponsored walk 75 years after serving in
Burma raising 30 million pounds for the
NHS this weekend was supposed to be a
celebration for World War two veterans
like Tom instead they find themselves
among the most at risk from a new enemy
the challenge for charities to find a
way for them to see how much their
sacrifices are still appreciated Sam
Holder Sky News